there are approximately 285 million
people with visual impairments around
the world making your app accessible not
just opens it up to these users but it
has a potential to improve design for
everyone most people are familiar with
an accessibility service called talkback
which is a screen reader utility for
people who are blind and visually
impaired with talkback the user performs
input via gestures such as swiping or
dragging or an external keyboard the
output is usually spoken feedback there
are two gesture input modes the first
one is touch exploration where you drag
your finger across the screen and the
second one is linear navigation or you
swipe left and right with your finger
until you find the item of interest once
you arrive to the item you're interested
in you double tap on it to activate the
primary way in which you can attach
alternative text description for your UI
elements to be spoken by talkback is by
using an Android attribute called
content description if you don't provide
content description for an image button
for example the experience for a
talkback user can be jarring unlabeled
button DoubleTap to activate unlabeled
button DoubleTap to activate for
decorative elements such as spacers and
dividers setting content description to
null will tell talkback to ignore and
not speak these elements make sure to
not include control type or control
state in your content description words
like buttons selected checked etc as
Android natively does that for you
Android lint automatically show you
which UI controls like content
descriptions to keep talkback spoken
output ID you can arrange related
content into groups by using focusable
containers when talkback encounters such
a container it will present the content
as a single announcement
for more complex structures such as
tables you can assign focus to a
container holding one piece of the
structure such as a single row grouping
content both reduces the amount of
swiping the user has to do while
streamlining speech output here is an
example of how ungroup table content
works song details name Hey Jude artists
the Beatles cost one dollar and forty
five cents and here's the same content
with grouping applied content grouping
activity song details name Hey Jude
artists the Beatles cost one dollar and
forty five cents
you should manually test your app with
talkback and eyes closed
to understand how a blind user may
experience it we also provide
accessibility scanner as an app in
Google Play it suggests accessibility
improvements automatically by looking at
content labels clickable items contrast
and more vision impairments doesn't just
refer to blindness 65% of our population
is farsighted for example with careful
design you can make sure that many of
your visually impaired users can have a
positive experience without having to
rely on talkback begin by making sure
that you eye of your apps works with
other accessibility settings including
increased font size and magnification
keep your touch targets large at least
48 by 48 DP this makes them easier to
distinguish and touch provide adequate
color contrast the World Wide Web
Consortium created color contrast
accessibility guidelines to help and to
assist users with color deficiencies use
cues other than color to distinguish UI
elements for example more descriptive
instructional text if you're using
custom views or draw in your app window
using OpenGL you need to manually define
accessibility metadata
so that accessibility services can
interpret your app properly the easiest
way to achieve this goal is to rely on
the explore by touch helper class with
just a few methods you can build a
hierarchy of virtual views that are
accessible to talkback
making your app accessible doesn't just
open it to new users it helps to make
the world a better place one app at a
time to read more about developing and
testing your apps for users with visual
impairments check out the links below
also check out the video on developing
for users with motor impairments
you
[Music]